[Musique]
charcuterie fromage cidre ou encore
sirop d'érable c'est la 7e édition du
Paris fermer à la Bergerie Nationale de
rambouillé du 9 au 11 novembre 110
producteurs de toute la France sont
venus présenter leur production les
producteurs fermers en France ont besoin
de se regrouper pour venir voir les
consommateurs les consommateurs qu'on
voit l'été mais qui voulaient nous
retrouver au cours de l'année donc on on
vient à leur porte leur apporter nos
produits avec notre image notre
savoir-faire et nos exploitations et en
plus l'avantage de venir à La Bergerie
national c'est qu'ici on est dans notre
élément on est dans une ferme on a les
pieds dans la bouse on est avec nos
bottes c'est parfait et c'est ce qui
nous caractérise le plus et c'est là où
on sent le mieux Paris fermier est un
groupement de 250 producteurs qui
organisent des événements de ce type
depuis 20 ans parmi les producteurs
ivelinois présent lors de cette édition
le boucher de la Bergerie Nationale dont
les produits varient chaque semaine tout
ce découpe d'agneau chipo et mergais et
le lait et les œufs bio de la bergerie
toutes les semaines on a un nouveau
produit ça peut être de la viand de
vache ou de l'agneau ou du porc c'est la
5è fois que cette famille du valdoise
vient au parisfermier une démarche
pédagogique pour ce papa leur faire
découvrir qu'il y a autre chose que ce
qu'on trouve dans la grande distribution
des des produits
fermiers avec des méthodes respectueuses
de la nature de l'environnement puis le
contact humain surtout qu'on qu'on a pas
dans région parisienne qu'on a de moins
en moins parce qu'on fait les courses
évidemment dans les grandes surfaces
alimentaires et cette édition aura
permis à environ 12000 visiteurs de
goûter des produits du terroir les
producteurs reviendront au beau jour à
la Bergerie Nationale pour proposer
leurs produits de
printemps